we've been telling you for months now
about the growing power of the big tech
companies whose brand of surveillance
capitalism has come to shape our
politics and culture in ways that many
people don't perceive tonight we're
going to give you a very specific
example of that it's both a look into
the near future and a terrifying
illustration of the control these
companies seek over our daily lives we
recently reviewed several patents filed
by Google as we described them ask
yourself if you're comfortable giving
this much power to unelected technocrats
you have never met in the first patent
filed in September of 2016
Google envisions how it could send you
personalized advertising based on what a
camera observes in your home in the
illustration that Google submitted to
the federal government the Patent Office
a camera in your bedroom sees a
godfather novel on your nightstand next
to your bed and uses that to steer you
to watching the movie you think that's
creepy prepare yourself because it gets
a lot creepier in another patent
application from September 2016
Google imagines how it could take
control of your parenting your
relationship with your children who will
smart home system could detect children
near a liquor cabinet for example or in
their parents bedroom infer that quote
mischief is occurring and deliver a
verbal warning another example google
imagines a hypothetical child called
Benjamin Google's cameras would be
watching Benjamin at all times carefully
they could see if he's playing outside
or using electronics presumably they
also try to use that information to sell
him things at some point because that's
the whole point of Google the same
patent also disgusts discusses have the
smart home could coach families unquote
areas of improvement for example if a
family doesn't spend enough time
together eating together in Google's
estimation Google might scold them and
suggest that they set a goal of eating
more often together that is Google's
description not ours by the way we
contacted Google for comment on this in
the company and we're assuming it was a
person and not a robot replied this way
quote we file patent applications on a
variety of ideas that our employees come
up with some of those ideas later mature
into real products or services some
don't in other words don't worry we're
not spying on you
yet we just have the patent for it
of course Tech is also dangerous because
it is deeply addictive in fact more than
anything it's deeply addictive now a
group of early Google and Facebook
employees are teaming up to check the
companies they helped create first on
Harris is a former Google employee heads
up this new group the Center for Humane
Technology Jim Steyer is the founder of
Common Sense Media which advocates for
children and they join us tonight thank
you both for coming you describe these
products as addictive what do you mean
by that well and what most people don't
realize they see addiction anything it's
happening by accident we're addicted to
lots of things we worried about our you
know our kids in nineteen seventies they
were addicted to gossiping on the
telephone what this misses is that today
behind the other side of the screen when
you're using it there's a hundred
engineers whose entire job not because
they're evil but their job is to figure
out how do I keep you coming back to the
product so YouTube wants to autoplay the
next video
snapchat wants to put the number of days
in a row and something called a streak
next to every single person in your kids
context they say if you've got 30
friends they say here's the number of
days in a row you've spit you've sent a
message to each friend and it keeps each
of them hooked because the business
models so long as it's advertising is
how do I hold on to your attention
because the entire stock price is one to
one linked with how much attention I get
and that's the problem so we know Jim
that screen time has consequences and it
hurts children correct can can it can
and there are a lot of disturbing
metrics about how kids and young adults
are doing and some of them are linked to
tech use so why has there been no public
recognition of this no widespread you
know it's interesting because I run
common sense the biggest kids media
group in the country it's taken time I
think part of it is we got so excited
about the incredible technological
innovation yes non-valid brought us and
there are amazing we're not anti tech
just on work at Google you know we're
not anti tech at all common sense helps
you find the good stuff but there's
clearly been no regulation whatsoever
there's not even at the size title no
real discussion and I think what's
happening you know Europe dad just like
I am my kids are starting to go I'm not
sure I really want this in my life all
the time I don't want this constantly
pinging me or wanting me to come there
and I think I mean trust on told you how
what addiction is but sixty percent of
kids you know if they believe they're
addicted to the
celfon that's a really big deal did the
tech companies know that so you worked
in them yes are they aware they must be
aware you're saying they designed this
to be addictive do they have moral
qualms about those so actually in 2013 I
created a presentation it was the first
Google memo before the second one got
really famous saying we have a moral
responsibility as Google because no
matter what we do or bump our elbow and
a billion people's attention goes that
way yes well you bump your elven and
billion people's attention goes that way
so how do you f ik Lee steer 2 billion
people actually their thoughts when they
look at a smartphone or a feed because
from the moment we wake up in the
morning to a hundred fifty times we
check per day it's like it's never been
easier to see as a kid you see if you
wake up you check your phone and you see
photo after photo of your friends having
fun without you is that how we want to
ethically care for for all these
millions and millions of kids attention
do you think Jim that there are enough
people with these companies who can see
clearly enough to pull back from this
little thang he is at the top because
the here's the deal you tristana
whistleblower this is the cigarette case
oh just on it and it's we were just with
a group of his engineering colleagues
who come forward and say enough is
enough we got to tell you this was
intentional' so the key is the
leadership at the top I actually tell
you this is a major challenge now to the
people at the very top of the key tech
companies in the United States what
values do you have is it just about how
much money you can make and how much
attention how much the arms race of
attention you can win so you can
monetize it by selling ads or if their
other value I couldn't and in you and by
the way this is not a partisan issue by
the way exact but you know everybody is
a parent nobody feels it all across the
country and it's kind of wrecking the
society and I think we all feel that way
and they're like how do you hold them
until I saw Willie Godspeed I hope
you'll come back in we will please do
thank you thank you good to see you talk